Welcome to The David Pakman Show, I'm Farron
Cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in for David
Pakman again today, but don't worry, folks, David
will return on Monday with fresh content for you.
I did in fact confirm that with him today. So he
will be back and I thank you all for watching this
week as I've been filling in. It is a great honor,
a great opportunity. Thank you to David. Thank
you to Pat. Thank you to everybody with this show.
It's a wonderful, wonderful thing to be able to do
and the audience. You all are absolutely fantastic
as well. And because of that, I'm giving you
a special treat today. I am actually kicking off
this show with an entire segment filled with good,
positive news. Now, as we all know in this, I
guess profession, if you want to call it that, we
don't get to talk about good things very
often. Usually it's how things have gone wrong,
how things could go wrong, the craziness coming
from our politicians. But and of course, we have
all of that coming up later. But for right now,
folks. Good news. And the first piece of good news
is that the FDA has authorized thes very first
COVID treatment pill from Pfizer that they're
predicting will be available in a matter of days.
And this comes as we talked yesterday, as Omicron
has now overtaken become the predominant strain
of COVID here in the United States. More than 73
percent of new cases are Omicron. And of course,
the graphs are going back up or seeing another
upward curve. So getting this treatment, having
this finally be available for the first time
is a huge positive development in our
handling of the pandemic. Because let's
be honest, we know that the vaccines are
effective. We know that the vaccines have been
preventing people from getting serious illness
have been preventing lots and lots of deaths.
But it's not enough because not enough people
are getting it. That's how we end up with more
mutations and more different variants. And of
course, the increasing deaths and number of cases
having this treatment gives us
really this two pronged attack
against the virus itself. Now this treatment, the
pill called Pax, love it again produced by Pfizer.
The administration has already pledged
more than $5 billion to purchase about 10
million doses from Pfizer over
the course of the next year.
10 million doses is not very much. I mean, when
we're talking about the grand scope of COVID here
in the United States, 10 million isn't going to
get us very far. Pfizer says, however, they're
hoping to be able to produce between 80 and 120
million doses within the next 12 months. So that's
good. That might be enough. So what we know so far
is in the early days, much like with the vaccines,
the priority for these COVID pills is going to go
to the elderly, those 65 and older and those with
high risk co-morbidities, chronic lung problems,
asthma, diabetes, heart problems. So again,
that's very similar to what we saw in the early
days of the vaccine rollout. And then hopefully,
once that is kind of under control, once
we get more production going, it will be
widely available to anyone who comes down with
COVID. And Pfizer also tells us another bit of
good news. They have every reason to believe
that this treatment will also be effective
against the Omicron variant, which
obviously wasn't a thing when they were
doing their testing. But they believe it
should be just as effective. And here's why
it all has to do with how the treatment itself
works, which here it is. This From Wall Street
Journal researchers designed the pill to stop the
coronavirus from spreading in people by blocking
activity of a key enzyme known as protease.
And my apologies if I'm mispronouncing that
which the virus needs to replicate. The
enzyme is enzyme isn't believed to be
mutated in Omicron, which is why Pfizer and
other researchers say the antiviral likely
will work against Omicron. The authorization
comes after researchers found PAX louvered was
safe and cut the risk of hospitalization
or death by about 80 nine percent.
If people at high risk of severe COVID took
the pill within three days of diagnosis,
treatment was also highly effective if begun
within five days of symptoms. So what's great
about that is it's not one of those
treatments where once you show symptoms?
Oh no, the treatment's not going to work. No,
you basically have a timetable of if you can
get it within three to five days of first showing
symptoms. This thing has a real chance, you know,
89 percent chance of reducing the risk of
hospitalization or death. So that brings
in another part of this. Early detection.
People have to know if the symptoms they're
exhibiting are COVID, or maybe it's a flu.
Maybe it's a cold, maybe it's something else.
So that's where these at home testing kits come
into play. And the administration this week said
they're going to give 500 million at home tests
out to the public. You know, free of charge. You
don't have to pay for these things. Five hundred
mil, we need more. We're going to need more.
And they need to not just be available. It's
time use your power. Send them to people's homes.
That's what needs to happen here. Sure, you're
going to have some nutty people out there that
just throw them out and we're going to see
videos about it online. But the risk is less
than the reward. Because people have to get
that early detection, so they know right away
when they get the sniffles, Oh, this is COVID.
Let me go see if I can get that treatment pill,
knock this out and avoid something far worse from
happening to me. So again, hugely positive story.
Combined with the vaccines,
we may finally be on track
to get this pandemic under control because
really the treatment for it has been the Big
X Factor so far. Up to this point, we haven't
had any kind of set treatment. You know,
it really has been not the kitchen sink part,
but it's been doctors just trying to keep people
alive. And that's great, they've done phenomenal
work, but we haven't been able to find something
to actually stop the violence virus, scuse
me from replicating inside of the human body
until this treatment. So this is good
news. This is highly positive. Hopefully,
Pfizer can ramp up their production, which is what
they're hoping to be able to do to get more and
more doses out there. And if this works, and of
course, if we can get this spread around the globe
so that everybody has access to the treatment, not
just us here, if we can do that, we may finally
get this pandemic not just under control,
but maybe even eradicated in the future